i don't know if you know this or not but
a lot of inflation is out there these
days
came out and said six percent this year
year over year six percent inflation so
your bank account
lost six percent of its purchasing power
let's break down what that means so
money as they say is a tool it's just a
tool or a financial instrument to get
what you want it doesn't actually have
value it's
the value you can get from it right it's
based on what the money can buy it's a
medium of exchange yeah so that money
went down six percent you can buy six
percent less stuff so
if you have a bank account and you've
got let's look like take some actual
examples here in your bank account
you've got 10 grand you think cool i'm
chilling on 10 grand right there that's
only purchasing power of
9 400
if you've got a hundred grand in the
bank what's up baby you're that dude
jose
found a hundred grand he's got a bag
hundred grand purchasing fat power 94
and then it went down when he called the
cops and then it went down big time when
he called the cops so inflation is real
six percent you know what's going on
obviously i'm all about save that money
save that money save that money save
that money get to a cushion where you're
comfortable and then invest i say this
all the time ninety percent of my wealth
mr save that money guy
is in the market is in finances his
investments i'm getting that compound
interest
let that thing grow and some of the
reasons why you know obviously after you
have a cushion
where can you put the money now savings
accounts pay zero zero i mean the point
with basis points we talked about 0.0012
0.004 oh we got a new savings account
we're giving you 0.03 now okay great
it's paying next to nothing right bonds
old people got bonds rich people got
bonds if you're looking to grow your
money bonds ain't to play treasury bills
government bonds bills paying like one
and a half percent next to nothing
traditionally gold which is a good
um
[Music]
what's the word hedge
hedge against inflation that's actually
been flat the past year but the stock
market baby it's been up over 10 for the
last decade this year to date 16 we
talked about this before and bitcoin and
crypto to the moon
so
the goal is to have enough money in
cash that you can move
from being in debt
to being a saver to be an investor
red light yellow light green light red
light is dead right yellow light saving
green light investing to the moon you
know what is the great warren muffet
buffett said about being inflation
proof he says
be the best
at what you are be the absolute best
whether you're a producer whether you're
a dentist whether you're a teacher
whether you're a politician whatever it
is
being inflation-proof is being the best
and what you do he says the best
investment is in yourself so if you guys
are listening out there and you're
getting out of debt and you're saving
that money you're on the right track
you've done two out of three now it's
time to invest baby
so
that's that quick thoughts on that david
before we move on no six percent
it's
obviously pbd did a video on this that
he released it's on youtube but yeah
it's it's scary something that um you
don't want to see especially i mean
you're not surprised coming out of a
pandemic kind of seeing this but it's
also not all the money printing all the
money all the stemies that are out there
scary i wish i had like uh
you know
more knowledge to give a better
opinion but it's just it's obviously
something
i don't want to see and i don't want to
see again yeah but i'm sure i will
marcelo i know you're working hard to
get to the 10 grand level now to put
your business on the street you're
getting close but what happens if you
were to find out that your 10 grand is
actually only 9 400. i wouldn't care
all right
no um
no honestly i think that um i have a
much i have a long term plan like i'm
not thinking about inflation at all
right now i'm in a place in my business
where all i'm thinking about is getting
more work and getting my product better
and making my business aka being the
best at what you do yeah i'm just trying
to become the best of what i do i don't
care about inflation i don't care about
investments i don't care about the stock
market i'm trying to become the best
comedic personality tunnel vision baby
let me tell you something
there's a part of me that's like oh this
kid don't know about inflation but
there's a part of me that actually
agrees with you right we can't control
the freaking inflation it is what it is
right yeah you know we talk about it we
spent an hour on it on pbd podcasts i'm
thinking guys
it is what it is what are we going to do
about it you can control what you can
control right i mean danielle danielle
di martino but he's an economist she can
maybe actually control some of this
stuff i don't know what you can do
but like your perspective there's not a
lot you can do to control inflation save
that money get out of debt invest that
money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sazcast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken